you
hi everyone is cherry this is a round
eight game from the 2017 Isle of Man
masters tournament between Fabiano Cara
Juana playing on the white end and the
current champ Magnus Carlsen this was
played today September 30th and who
knows this game may very well turn out
to be a preview game for the next World
Chess Championship match
Cara Juana certainly came very close to
becoming challenger for the last
championship so let's dive in here
Caruana
opening up with eform we have a royal
apes' on board and either player blinks
far about the first 15 moves neither
player caught off guard well with in
preparation Carlsen electing a more
aggressive deployment with the bishop
plenty of games with Bishop to e7 not
here c3 d6
black doesn't want to budge with the
b-pawn and give up control of c4 so
easily so rook to b8 deform and Bishop
to b6 this tension by the way keep a
very close eye on it it doesn't change
for what feels like the whole game
neither side initiates a capture for a
great period of time and why is that the
case well neither side feels that it
would be benefiting them so that a five
pawn in the d4 pawn stay put
following up we have a five that guy's
poison
taking with the bishop would be met with
white scaring away the night and then
picking up the bishop and taking what
the night is not good because of a chain
reaction of captures chop-chop trade of
Queens no longer in black castle and
that's really gonna hurt soon so black
of course knows this Bishop a7 H 3 H 3
and H 6 are typical in this opening by
the way this pawn cannot be picked up
because of a fork with Bishop to d5 so
after Bishop to e3 there are
possibilities for white to maybe take
and then take here and the rook is
simply there to now reinforce that
bishop post rook to e1 h6 black wants to
play this but doing so right away
mmm leaves f7 a little bit vulnerable so
that that's a little bit irritating so
first h6
and only now rip to e8
G 4 so this is the point I was talking
about the first 15 moves both players
started the game with 100 minutes you
gain in 30 seconds when you make a move
and they have
more time than they started with at this
point in the game until this point this
right here is the first think of the
game
Carlson spent some time here and chooses
Queen to e7 this is a very committal
move for sure the most committal move
many weaknesses on the King side what's
what's the idea connected with this well
the knight wants to have this type of
idea in mind we're not quite there just
yet but okay Queenie 7 9 f 1 and Knight
to d8 where is this Knight headed well
now that these squares are weakened this
is a possibility but it's not so easily
realized because if the knight ever
steps foot on the e6 square Y can chop
away on e5 so there is an additional
idea behind Knight to d8 can you spot it
what's the additional idea I'm just
going to move forward what is it
let's see Knight g3 the next move is
going to reveal what this idea is c5 at
night was getting in the sea pawns way
he's now contributing to the fight in
the center more pressure on d4
does not budge Queen to d2 see for
grabbing some queenside space Bishop c2
and a little bit of a reorganization I
was pointing out that this isn't so easy
to try to get in and key in on the let's
say the F for square because of the
pressure White has on e5 but maybe there
is an idea for this night to circle into
g6 and I up the FF for square like so
continuing b4
we have now a capture this is a you know
this is a big moment in the game be for
grabbing some space this is one of these
now-or-never moments if you want to
capture on b4 of course Carlsen goes for
it
taking on b3 it's not the only option
you could consider Queen to f6 putting
more pressure on the d4 point and
playing within this structure but black
has a different idea in mind capturing
on b3 a5 is something black is thinking
about by capturing on b3 right now it's
capture a5 is a little bit vulnerable
Bishop takes and now we have Bishop to
e6 this is where there's an issue with
White's reply the game move is Bishop to
c2 and there is some advantage for white
in this position related to having some
space on the Queen side but more so the
President on presence in the center d4e
for structure versus d6 + e5 white is
for choice when it's when you compare
the structures in the center
the move to really look into is Knight
to f5 and of course I could say this
with great confidence because I'm I
analyzed this with my great friend
stockfish eight and this is the
recommendation by stockfish to leap into
f5 not quite sure I can't put my finger
on why exactly that move wasn't played
it certainly looks looks extra appealing
and I thought that that was one of the
ideas behind playing G form to support
this Knight jump into f5 I'd like to
take a look at the move Knight to f5
again the game move was Bishop to c2 but
this is an important moment in the game
21 moves in and yeah it's wrap this game
wraps up by move thirty-five Knight to
f5 do you tolerate the night I mean you
does black try to work around this guy
uh it appears like you have to get rid
of them and now we have a great shift
both structurally and minor piece wise
this Bishop on b3 he is a knife and what
is really close right around the corner
what we're going to observe is a king h2
root 2 G 1 and there sure seems to be a
whole lot of white pieces pointing at
the black position I don't know that
might my initial impression of this is
it feels it's really scary you know I'm
not quite sure what this night would it
be doing what's his place especially now
that the pawn is taking out e6 there's a
lot of traffic and let's just say a lot
of just drawing some lines towards the
black King side it looks very scary I
would not be surprised if we at the top
level I would not be surprised if this
position right here is not seen again I
don't think black would enter this
position again because the players are
certainly going to do their homework
this position and C Knight to f5 you
know what that's getting extra scary
when you have three white pieces
converging on h6 as well and potential
open G file okay
that wasn't played no Knight f5 Bishop
c2 in the game so retreating instead of
leaping in their continuing Rick to see
a very logical that's a half-open file
and here we go theme keto tonight
pressure on a five the queen is ready to
now drop back to d8 in the event of
Knight to f5 this wasn't an option
before when the knight was on f5 so rook
to c1 again if he goes here the Queen
goes home and maybe black picks up a
pawn and then looks at these two squares
rook c1 in the game Queen to d8 Queen -
B - there's no good way to defend the a5
pawn this is again one of the ideas I
imagine black had by making that capture
on b3 sensing that the a 5-pound could
be a target later on and it is and in
the game it is picked up
Knight to d2 I'm backing up and this is
where Carlson now presses in the center
with d5 these these these are moves that
you know I like to make these kind of
moves in the game what do I mean by that
well you're you find your opponent they
back up the step and then you just kind
of lash out in the center and say you
know what let's crack things open you
backed up I'm moving forward that kind
of mentality and it's super volatile in
the center this tension is still present
but okay things are going to change very
soon at this point
Ricci one
you know you can't capture like this at
this point rook to e1 you can't take
like this because that's gonna that's
gonna hurt really really bad King is
already super weak and if this F pawn is
now on III that's gonna be trouble
so rook to e1 maybe now this is an idea
Bishop to b8 simply reinforcing the
points black is prepared to me
each of these captures with a recapture
improving the quality of one of the
pieces with that recapture he takes D
Bishop takes Bishop to f5 and the rook
is able to react and move forward
rook to c6 defending a6 so now the
knight is able to move forward well not
to be three but c4 is certainly a
possibility and who knows maybe some
rook swing it's a very convenient reply
sometimes you're you know your opponent
throws or strikes it strike at you and
you have to react in a way that's
strictly defensive so this is you know
this is not an inconvenience stepping up
like this a couple ranks there's a
purpose now
continuing queen to a three and it's
worth noting okay this is move
thirty-five moves out from game over I
think there's an interesting this is an
interesting moment timewise you know I
don't have an exact time for each player
but Caruana is it just has a few minutes
let's say five minutes
ballpark remaining and Carlson has
around a half hour the game move here is
night to be seven and this initially
struck me as a little bit odd because I
thought well why not jump in to see for
the computer kind of evaluates both of
these moves here as equal ish and I
could see why you may want to play
Knight to be seven instead of Knight to
c4 Knight to c4
it gives white and easy reply you
basically just have to take that night
out and the thing and the position
becomes a little bit more simplified
your one less piece off I can't say with
certainty this is the reason behind
Knight to b7 and wanting to let's say
keep pieces more pieces on the board
because you have more time and could
assess the complications a little bit
better but maybe maybe that is a train
of thought that black hat at this point
continuing night b7 rook a to D 1 e
takes D Bishop takes and here we go
Knight to g5 he wasn't doing anything on
h7 but when he jumps in
he's jumping in with great effect many
squares IDE up h3 is weak
F 3 square and yet there's an issue on F
3 as we will soon see C 4 is tried
allowing the Queen to watch over F 3 but
we have one rakov Bishop to e6 welcoming
some exchanges black is up a pawn
Queen to e3 is a game losing move it was
already extremely difficult for white
losing even before this last move but
there is one final move by Carlsen here
that makes white resigned so quick pop
quiz to you what move did Carlson play
that made Cara wanna cry
okay the last move of the game
Bishop to f4
and with this Caruana resigns because
queen takes bishop would be met with a
fork that hurts and suppose you do
something else well we take the knight
we win a piece and if you take back
another fork would be present a tricky
night so that's the final move of the
game and if you're curious about the
quality of play of these two players let
me pull up the graph so you could see
this these average sent upon loss that
the players had just quickly going
through wide advantage until what point
right here Bishop e6 and that's why I
wanted to pay some attention to this
moment right here Bishop to c2 that's
where this advantage that white had was
thrown away and it's one of those give
him an inch and he takes a yard and it
went downhill very very fast from their
team white Caruana
for inaccuracy zero mistakes one blunder
average sent upon loss of thirty-four
the lower the number the better team
black one zero zero fourteen for an
average sent upon loss so that's the
tale of the tape with this one and feel
free as usual to leave any feedback in
the comment section below and I'll catch
you in the next video that's all for now
take care bye
you